[Music]
my name is audric do campo I am
urban beekeepers i'm the most
happy men because my office
it's a roof the sky of paris and
bees
[Music]
I am a stressed anxious a
hyperactive on a hive you can only
not be anxious and stressed because
what do you feel it makes you sting you
does a bad job
so in fact it's the best at
relaxing I've never found it's from
work the bees because that's me
force to be focus focused and
to forget the sweet sweet bise time
I did not start only bees
I am originally from Paris but my
parents have a champagne house and
and then I was every weekend I
started planting radish salads
tomatoes then I said to myself bah he
need a hive what and then there it was
more complicated because my father is
allergic we are looking for roofs
who take relatively the sun and
then simply we are happy to
produce honey for our guests
I started in Paris to the disabled
then was the military school the museum
d'orsay then here the blue cordon etc
etc.
the story is written every day on
works with bees according to their
pace
[Music]
so I chnique dressed you congratulate
80% of the plants on this planet depends
for their survival their reproduction of
pollinators
it's bees doing this work
almost free for a
thirty years one realizes that one loses
more and more our with the greens because
that you have to know is that the town hall of
Paris
treats green spaces in organic since
twenty years the goal is
really to have an ultra production
local paris to these micro honey climate
it is extraordinary to open a hive
it's really exciting because
you have some kind of comparing it's a
mackerel organism that will act with a
collective intelligence
she will make decisions and what
is great that we can compare the
hive to a small business where every
bee will make career
throughout his life as needed
of the common good is in fact a society
perfect and I fell in love with
my daughters
this for the world I will do another
profession like me I hope modestly I
want to inspire people with beauty
love of the beauty of monuments
the love of the mom of paris but
the love of taste transmitted by the palate
I will talk about aesthetics of taste in
philosopher
[Music]
it